so as we get into this video about the
purple man there are a couple things
that I want to bring up the first is
that this video will have some content
that draws on Marvel's adult lineup
which means we'll be discussing some
adult situations the second is that over
the years of his publication history
while purple man made his debut with
daredevil issue number four daredevil
has had his origins retold several times
including his first encounter with the
purple man and truth the retelling of
Daredevils origin was largely contextual
and it Stanley provided the origin as an
introduction while future writers like
Frank Miller changed the origin based on
his desire to create an even darker
character and so in 2002 as part of his
Marvel color series rewriting the origin
stories of popular characters to return
them to their roots
Jeff lobe introduced daredevil yellow
using issue number 6 as a way to provide
an updated depiction of purple man's
first appearance while maintaining much
of the original content from 1964 s
daredevil issue number four
so the origin of purple man comes to us
into comics daredevil issue number four
and alpha flight issue number 41 however
because the story's a purple man work in
textual to the narrative at the time
these stories as a provided us are given
over the course of a single page or so
each beginning with daredevil issue
number four in this story we learned
that zebediah killgrave was previously a
croatian spy working for the Soviet bloc
and was assigned the task of entering an
American army weapons depot to attain a
sample of an experimental nerve agent
while he was able to access the area
housing the nerve agent itself he was
spotted by one of the guards engaging in
a firefight the American soldier hid the
canister behind kilgrave allowing the
purple nerve agent to escape dousing
kilgrave and the chemicals and turning
his skin purple he then concocted a
story stating that the entire situation
was an accident with the guards
believing him and standing down kilgrave
began to realize that the nerve toxin
had allowed him to emit pheromones have
been the wills of others to his own ends
now from here we switched to alpha
flight issue 41 and told from the
perspective of purple man's daughter
named Kara the story of how she came to
be is tied directly to the history of
kilgrave himself what we're told is that
at some point between gaining his
abilities his appearance in Hell's
Kitchen and subsequent encounter with
daredevil kilgrave had encountered a
woman named Melanie at a bar in Buffalo
New York while she and a friend were
waiting on their dates the initial
response of Melanie's friend is to send
kilgrave away due to his physical
appearance however because he can
control the wills of others killgrave
uses his powers to force Melanie to
marry him that night however as time
passed he eventually fell in love with
Melanie relinquishing her from his mind
control Melanie came to the realization
of what purple man had been doing and
that he had used her for his own ends
fleeing from their home and taking up
residence in Toronto
Melanie realizes she had become pregnant
with kilgrave's daughter and so carrying
the child at her and naming her Keira
kilgrave's daughter progressed normally
throughout her childhood until she
turned 13 at which point her skin turned
purple and she inherited her father's
powers
so the story of how purple man is
introduced and how it was that he first
met daredevil starts with foggy Nelson
and Matt Murdock alongside their
assistant Karen page as are assigned to
represent the purple man after he had
been arrested for robbery while foggy
expresses a distaste about this his
irritation is do more to frustration
over having to take court-appointed
cases as opposed to what he considers
legitimate work now once they arrive at
the county jail
while Karen Paige is enamored with the
concept of daredevil even though she
still doesn't know that daredevil is
Matt Murdock the two approached the cell
as ever do
now something I'd like you to notice
here is that Marvel uses the color
purple to illustrate those under the
control of the purple man but more so
than that a purple man himself states
that he has no need for a lawyer and
instructs the guard to let him out of
his cell unable to resist the purple
man's mind-control the guard does as
instructed after which Karen is placed
under zebediah killgrave control and
leaves with him now in the original
story from 1984 Stan Lee and Bill
Everett were still fleshing out Matt
Murdock's abilities and incorporated his
own willpower as a means to overcome
mind control and so picking up on this
cue Jeph Loeb maintains the same trend
by establishing that not only is dirty
devil able to resist the mind-control of
purple man but he was also able to
immediately deduce that purple man had
the ability to overcome the willpower of
others and control them accordingly
however where Jeff Lowe begins to take a
few liberties is when Karen leaves the
jail with purple man himself and the
original story he had simply left with
Karen page and when he was pursued by
daredevil uses powers to bend a street
full of people to his will and turn them
into an army of sorts with daredevil
yellow as they leave the jail
daredevil arrives to save Karen at which
point zebediah has the guards and the
street turned their guns on Matt Murdock
with the intention of killing him
now I'd like you to remember the kind of
sociopathic nature he's demonstrating
here as well as is dislike of daredevil
because this will become extremely
important for our discussion when we get
to Jessica Jones
what I'd also like you to notice is that
as purple man moves away from the police
officers his control over them seems to
dissipate as well now this is something
that we will see over the course of its
publication history but it won't
actually be explored any further until
we get to Brian Michael Bendis in the
introduction of Jessica Jones in 2001
now with a story shows purple man taking
up residence in a penthouse suite of a
hotel
Jeff lobe simultaneously provides us
with a little insight into how daredevil
views kilgrave in relation to others
like kingpin bullseye and dr. doom what
he tells us is that those individuals
always desire power whether it be
complete control of the criminal world
in New York or world domination their
motives were at their core archetypical
of almost all villains however the
purple man seems to desire Karen and
while king pandu m-- and bull's eye
posed a larger threat to the world as a
whole for daredevil losing Karen is
worse than any of that simply because of
the fact that he's basically in love
with her furthermore the true danger of
zebediah killgrave is highlighted when
daredevil arrives to stop the villain
and save Karen but for daredevil and all
superheroes the goal is to minimize
casualties while stopping the villain in
this story
Jeff lobe asks an important question
what happens when the danger of a
villain is not necessarily what they can
do to you so much is what they can make
other people do to themselves and so
using his control over Karen as a
distraction by forcing her to jump out
of the window daredevil is forced to
allow purple man to escape and rescue
Karen and the process and so as to take
to the street after Karen's rescue
purple man arrives assuming to control
the various citizens on the street
itself and so grabbing an overhang and
wrapping it around the purple man
thereby neutralizing his powers
daredevil instruction police to keep him
covered and they simply take him to jail
and so following purple man premiering
as a villain of daredevil while he
wasn't the most popular character of all
time there was still some interest in
his character the problem level faced
though was that because he appeared in
issue number four
almost impossible to determine if the
success of the story was due to purple
man with a growing popularity of
daredevil as a result Marvel began to
experiment with his character by
building him up into a super villain and
taking place in daredevil issues 88 and
89 the story saw zebediah killgrave
building a criminal empire for himself
as we discussed in my video about
daredevil
the problem with this story was that
when Gerry Conway had taken over the
title with issue number 72 by issue
number 81
daredevil had been moved to San
Francisco some of the fans absolutely
hated and so as a result Marvel's
efforts regarding the purple man were
basically in vain as a series began to
fall into a state of decline with
readership dropping off as a result with
Gerry Conway removed from the stories
with issue number 97 and replaced by a
series of riders leading up to Marv
Wolfman with issues number 134 through
154 Marv Wolfman introduced a series of
backup features tying in to the main
stories that saw zebediah killgrave
seizing control of a man named Maxwell
Glen looking to make himself head of
Glenn industries and truth by the time
this arc him around in 1977 characters
like Luke Cage storm Moon Knight and
Carol Danvers alongside the Fantastic
Four spider-man and the x-men were
either appearing for the first time or
soaring to greater heights and
popularity and with the daredevil titles
still recovering due to Gerry Conway's
run little room was left for Marvel to
build up a super villain in addition to
Daredevils existing rogues gallery of
bullseye kingpin and others following
the end of wolfman's run with purple man
puttering throughout Marvel occasionally
appearing in comics like Marvel team-up
annual number for 1981 by Frank Miller
and x-men number 34 and 1998 by Terry
Cavanagh
it wasn't until Brian Michael Bendis
azalea's series that he found himself
becoming a fan favorite among readers
so in my video about Jessica Jones we
had talked about how she was created by
Brian Michael Bendis in 2001 under the
coming book title of alias as part of
the Marvel max lineup containing adult
oriented material and in an effort to
provide her with a truly harrowing
backstory
Bendis established that Jessica Jones
had developed super-strength enhanced
durability and flight following a car
crash with a truck carrying radioactive
materials that claimed the lives of her
family and doused her in the radioactive
material taking the name jewel and
becoming a superhero after witnessing
spider-man fighting the scorpion
Bendis introduced the purple man as a
way to darken her origin and provide
readers with a backstory that hadn't
quite been seen before covered in a
five-part story titled purple which
explained why Jessica Jones had become a
private detective and abandoned her role
as a superhero an issue number 20 for
her services are contracted by a group
of individuals who were related to
thirty-four people all of whom died at a
Denny's when kilgrave walked in and
ordered them to stop breathing due to
the fact that he wanted to eat with no
noise while she agreed to take the case
this decision came with trepidation
something which was explained to
Jessica's love interest Luke Cage what
we learn is that after she had taken the
name jewel and become a superhero she
responded to a conflict at a diner
involving two men beating one another
almost immediately after arriving and
because of kilgrave's physical
attraction to her Jessica Jones is
placed under his control
initially ordering her to take off her
clothes his order is rescinded when the
police arrive instructing her to take
out the police officers her inability to
resist his control forced her to travel
outside and trash the various cars
sending the police officers fleeing for
their lives and so while under the
control of the purple man following this
incident kilgrave never actually forced
her to engage in sexual acts with him
and instead he would take college girls
off the street have his way with them
make her watch and beg to join them and
however during an instance when
daredevil had acted to save the city
killgrave lashed out due to his hatred
over Murdock ordering Jones supplying
daredevil kill him and never return she
promptly left the confines of kilgrave's
control now at this point Venice
provides more comprehensive explanation
of how kilgrave's powers affect those
under his control which was actually
something that we had never really seen
before what we're told is that the
further jessica jones traveled away
the pheromones the kilgrave put off the
less of an influence he had on her
however because he had her under his
control for almost a year the pheromones
he emitted became somewhat of a drug for
her body and her mind
however after spotting the Avengers she
subconsciously reached out for help by
attacking the Scarlet Witch between her
battle with the Avengers and the effects
of withdrawal due to being away from the
purple man's pheromones Jessica Jones
mind effectively shuts down and taken by
the Avengers and placed in a hospital
aboard a shield Helicarrier Jean Grey of
the x-men had placed mental blocks in
the mind of Jessica Jones in order to
protect her from the effects of the
purple man's control now following this
the discussion on Jessica Jones
continues in my video about her
character but in terms of the purple man
because a Marvel max imprint existed
outside of the main Marvel continuity in
2004 prior to the events of House of M
Civil War and as part of Joe Quesada s
attempt to consolidate popular
characters and teams into the main
Marvel Universe where Jessica Jones
continued to see some measure of
popularity due to her entire run in the
alias line the purple man fell back into
obscurity again with Marvel attending to
revitalize interest in the villain by
having him make appearances and events
leading up to the formation of the New
Avengers the Civil War event and fear
itself with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys on her Bruce